안녕하세요.
빌사남크 김윤수입니다. 제가 오늘은
빌딩 중계를 하면서 여러 가지 사례를
좀 말씀드릴 건데 가장 열심히 일하고
성과를 가장 많이 냈던 노현노
팀장님이 모셨습니다. 안녕하세요.
안녕하세요. 네. 안녕하세요.
간단하게 자기 소개 좀
부탁드리겠습니다. 안녕하세요. 저는
빌사남 중개법인에서 최단기 팀장을
여기만
이렇게 말해야 되나요? 네네. 열심히
하고 있는 팀장 그리고 공인중개사
노현호입니다. 반갑습니다. 네. 어,
지금 중계하신지는 얼마나 되셨죠?
지금 5년 차 되었습니다. 지금까지
일하시면서 사례들이 좀 있을까요?
기억이 남는 사례 엄청 많죠.
대표적으로 관심. 예. 뭐 대표적인
사례로 말씀을 드리자면은 어, 제가
이제 성수동에 있는 건물 두 피치를
계약을 하는 상황이었어요. 건물에
가서 어떤 하자가 있는지 한 번 더
체크하는 차원에서 살펴보고 있는데
어, 제 직원분은 전화가 왔습니다.
양님 죄송합니다. 매도자가 건물 안
판다고 합니다. 그게 무슨 소리냐?
지금 매수자 산다는데 그래서 거기
주소 어디냐라고 물어봐서 바로 일단은
습격을 했어요. 매도자 집으로직접
찾아가서 예. 바로 들어가서 왜 안
파진 이유가 뭔지 얘기를 들어보니까
그 건물은 명도 조건의 계약이었어요.
네네. 근데 본인들이 명도를 못
하겠다는 거예요. 제가 해결책을
드렸죠. 그럼 제가 명도를 하면은
매각을 하시겠냐? 말도 안 된다.
너가 어떻게 하냐라고 하시는 거예요.
그럼 명도하겠다. 네. 세 개가
있었거든요. 아, 세 개 있었어요.
예. 근데 어머님이 항상 만나러 갈
때면 그 세 명이 다 도망친다는
거예요. 차만 보여도 온다는 신호만
보여도 바로 도망친다는 거예요. 왜?
왜 도망쳐요? 명도 당하기 싫으니까.
당기 싫으니까. 그래서 아버님 그
전에 명도합비서 같은 거 있었냐?
명도합비서가 있는데 확실해 보이진
않더라고요. 그래서 제가 좀 수정을
해서이 명도 합의서로 오늘 도장을
받자 그럼 지금 가도 있을지 없을지
모른다. 일단 가자라고 해서 그 비
오는 날 습격을 했습니다. 바로 이제
명도합의서들이 내밀고 네. 거기서
명도 합의서를 작성을 했거든요.
명도가 될 수 있는 상황들이
있었어요. 그래서 그 상황을 제가
보고 이거는 이제 노하우가 있기
때문에 제가 말씀 다 드리기 어렵지만
명도 합의서를 다 받고 나와서
어머님께 말씀을 드렸죠. 어머니 나
수고했으니까 짜장면 한글을 사 달라.
어 다시 어머님 집에서 이제 짜장면을
먹으면서 이제 계약서까지 다 작성을
했어요. 동의를 하셨습니다. 근데
제가 앞서 말씀드렸던 것처럼 두
필지를 계약을 해야 되는 거였거든요.
근데 옆에 있는 필지가 안 팔면은
또이 물건을 사는게 의미가 없는
거예요. 그래서 어머님한테 그 오늘
옆에 있는 필지 사람을 설득할 때니
돈을 매수자가 보낸다고 하면은
계좌본을 달라라고 말씀을 드렸어요.
그래서 확답을 받고 바로 옆필지
소유자를 또 찾아갔습니다. 그 잠깐만
얘기를 하자라고 제가 앞으로 찾아가서
바로 계약을
하겠다음. 하니까 또 어머님이 또
계약을 갑자기 안 하시겠다는 거예요.
어. 근데 그 어머님을 붙잡고 한 세
시간을 설득을 했던 거 같아요. 근데
이제 본인이 또 세무사를 확인을 해야
된다는 거예요. 예. 그래서 제가
알고 있는 세무사를 대동해서 한번 더
이제 연결을 해서 좀 그 부분을 좀
해결해 드리고 생각하셨던 간급까지 다
메꿔 드리면서 어머님도 계좌를 열어
주셔서 그거 먼저 돈을 넣고 그다음에
동시에 또 옆필집까지 계약을
했었습니다. 그래서 코드명이
습격이었어요.
그래서 이게 사실 불가능한 걸
가능하게 만든 거거든요. 그래서 어
그때 8시간 정도가 걸렸거든요. 어.
예. 근데 끝났을 때 그 어떤 때보다
느끼지 못했던 그 희열감, 성취감이
있었어요. 되게 행복했던
순간이었습니다. 그 돈보다도 정말 안
되는 거를 해냈구나. 그 타이밍이
되게 좋았던 거 같아요. 그 임차인
세 명이 있었던 것도 어. 너무나
예, 큰 타이밍이었고 좋았던
살인입니다.
그렇구나. 뭐 저도 중개업을 하고
있지만 사실 이렇게 안 파는 걸
설득하는 건 진짜 쉽지 않은 건데
워낙 이제 좀 잘 설득하셔 가지고
이제 그렇게 계약까지 이루어졌던
사례인 거 같고 어 궁금한게 있어요
대표님 대표님 첫 계약은 어떤
건이었나요? 아 첫 계약은 그
역삼동에 있는 건물이었는데네
건물주분이 김포에 살았거든요. 계속
전화할 때마다 막 욕하고 그랬어요.
그렇죠. 그런 분들 많죠. 예. 되게
날카로우셨고 그러다 이제 제가
찾아가게 김포까지. 네. 진짜 한시간
반 동안 그 버스 타고 갔거든요.
가가지고 이제 주차장에서 만났는데 그
구물주분이 이제 네가 진짜 올 줄
몰랐다
그러면서 거기 앉은 자리에서 거의 한
20%를 깎아 줬어요. 그러고 나서
이제 바로 계약이 나왔었고 근데 이제
그거 매입을 했는데 거기 이제 2층
임차인이 있었는데 맨날 문을 안 열어
주는 거예요. 한 한 4년인가 지나고
나서 갑자기 그거 매입했던
건물주분한테 연락이 와서 태페업소로
적발됐다. 어 예 예 어 그래서이
통지사 이렇게 보내 주시더라고요.
그래서 이거 어떡하냐 그 태페업소의
썰이 있는데 이거는
한두시간짜리인데 대소를 해가지고
만나는데
[음악]
너 칼 맞아 봤냐?
새벽에 죄송합니다. 전 그분 그 인상
차기가 아직도 기억이 남아. 그때
너무 충격받아 가지고 저 만나자마자
한 마리 이제 너무 죽고 싶네했어요.
그때 만나서 잘 설득했죠. 이거
소송하면 100%지고 그냥 그거 받고
그냥 나가시는게 이득이라고.
[음악]